diameter is an indie soul's like where
you can dash like bloodborne and parry
like sekuro it's also kind of easy and
pretty short my first run through
clocked in around 8 hours and that's
completing every level and mission
within that short time there are moments
when the combat really clicks and you
find yourself getting into an engaging
and rewarding rhythm but there is also a
lot of asset reuse of levels and enemies
this definitely leads to issue given the
game's brevity with not too much time
between the start of the game and the
final boss you'd want as much of that
brief experience to be packed with
unique encounters and enemies by misa
suffers in this regard there is some
really great gameplay to be had but
those moments sometimes feel too few and
far between the drawbacks not
withstanding thymesia clearly shows its
mechanical skeleton to be that of the
souls-like genre and it can deliver the
high of thrilling combat that the souls
games are known for with more
development thymesia could have been a
standout if smaller souls like
experience but for now its shortcomings
rival or outnumber its successes in this
video i'll delve into the fruits and
failures of this plague themed action
rpg looking at how it utilizes the
subgenre's formula first we'll see a
broad overview of the overall design of
thinesia and how its success is linked
with its faults to put it briefly the
core combat has been well refined but
most other stuff hasn't then we'll go a
bit into detail about each aspect of the
game i'll avoid most spoilers till the
later part of the video and i'll say
when they come up though i'll show some
footage of the first bosses along with
some of each main area in the game if
you find yourself enjoying the video
consider subscribing as it helps the
channel out and with that let's get into
the imesia a critical review
in thimesia you play as corvus a
crow-human hybrid who looks like a
plague doctor which is fitting because
the game's setting the kingdom of hermes
is beset by a devastating plague along
with the plague killing and mutating
people there is also a presence of
alchemical research focusing largely on
two kinds of blood pure and vile which
is used in experiments and to strengthen
the player character corvus himself is a
result of this alchemical
experimentation playing as the crow man
is fun your combat kit from dodge to
slash to parry to claw to feather makes
for a dynamic toolset which keeps fights
high paced the player generally always
has something to do and they can choose
which avenue they want to go down
playing more passive and dodging playing
more aggressive and parrying or
something in between the combat can
really soar and i'll talk more about
that when i get into the details of how
it all works
for now i'll leave it with those
positive words to talk about the issues
of the game which is almost everything
else to start there are only three main
levels instead of an open or connected
world thymesia gives instance levels in
which you have to carry out missions
when you complete a level's main mission
you unlock the next level along with a
few optional missions sometimes there
are even more optional missions that
open up after completing preliminary
ones all in all there are three main
levels along with one final level which
is essentially just the final boss fight
in the three levels there are 12
missions in total with three core
missions and nine optional ones
just playing the core missions which
include three bosses plus the final boss
i finished a quick run-through of the
game in less than 1 hour with the
initial playthrough at less than 10
hours this should show you how short of
a game thymija is
this level formula works as a way to
increase the content in the game without
drastically increasing the development
work and that makes sense for the small
development team however the game is
already short so replaying levels
definitely takes a bit out of the
experience to be fair a lot of them do
situate you differently so you progress
in different ways or explore parts of
the level that aren't present in the
rest of the other missions there are
even one or two missions that do have
their complete own zone like their own
level or mini level so the
implementation isn't terrible but it is
still a bit lackluster and kind of
monotonous
there is also no new game plus at the
moment so what you have here is the
entirety of what you get you are able to
go back and replay all the boss fights
which is a definite plus and the game
even pushes you to do so to get certain
upgrades so you get to feel your
progression as you get more familiar
with the game which it shows each time
you face the boss there's an achievement
to beat a boss without healing and i
eventually went back and got that on the
first proper boss of the game which is
one of the more difficult ones and that
felt quite satisfying to do given my
original high death count to him
along with the level reuse the enemy
variety is also not stellar you'll find
similar night enemies and the same kind
of dude with sword for most of the game
as you progress you do come across
knights with special weapon types which
make for different gameplay but it's not
quite enough to keep things new
occasionally there is a more unique foe
like the whip enemy for instance and
these are a breath of fresh air that the
game could have used a good amount more
of these issues along with others like
no voice acting bosses being a little
bit too easy and a slight disconnect
between the lore and the realization of
it in enemies all detract from the game
bamija could have achieved a
comprehensive soul's effect even if on a
smaller scale but the lack of developed
content across multiple areas of the
game prevents this i enjoy the story and
lore concepts especially in the
pureblood vile blood dichotomy that
comes up throughout and the plagued
world building but the enemies just
don't deliver enough on these elements
the atmosphere and environment do a
pretty good job but with only three core
levels it just doesn't feel like there
is enough here as a preliminary general
conclusion dimeja has some solid highs
but it needs more development and more
distinct enemies you can see potential
in it and i think this studio has
potential too especially in their
ability to get the player into a
satisfying flow state though as the game
is now the issues are unavoidable in any
complete evaluation it still has its fun
and engaging moments it just needs more
of it
now that i've gone over the game
generally let's dive into the details
first we'll be expanding on my favorite
part of the game the combat lamia gives
the player five main tools for combat
dodge parry attack special attack or
claw and feather as i've already said
the dodge is a bit like bloodbornes fast
and short and the parry is a bit like
sekiro quick and a big part of taking
down enemies in this game you don't have
any stamina and enemies don't have a
posture bar but they do have something
like it when you pair enemies with your
dagger or attack them with your sword a
white health bar will deplete to reveal
a second green health bar this is the
wound bar and it must be depleted to
kill an enemy you can whittle this down
with basic sword attacks but it's pretty
slow going instead the game supplies you
with a special claw attack designed to
delete these wounds altogether these
four options plus the feather which i'll
come back to are what you use to take
down enemies dodge and parry their
attacks while landing hits of your own
and then lock in your damage with your
claw with the quickness of the parry you
can often deflect attacks almost
simultaneously with your claw swings
getting into the rhythm with a boss can
be pretty addicting this core combat is
modified by the game's leveling system
which takes a more streamlined approach
compared to the dozen or so stats
available for upgrade in souls games
instead there are just three stats to
choose from strength vitality and plague
upgrading strength increases your
sword's attack power upgrading vitality
gives you more health and upgrading play
gives you more energy and makes your
claw do more damage to wounds each time
you gain a level here you get one skill
point to invest in your various skilled
trees these can be changed at any time
so you are free to experiment with them
and they range in kind from increasing
your damage or feather count to giving
you new abilities counters and buffs to
return to energy and feathers energy is
what you expend when using plague
weapons which are basically special
kinds of attacks that you can unlock and
upgrade by defeating enemies who use the
same weapons a bow enemy can drop
materials which let you unlock the bow
plague weapon a spear enemy the spear
plague weapon and so on these plague
weapons have cooldowns and energy costs
but you can get energy back through the
use of your claw and potions others are
projectiles which slowly regenerate
after use and they are first introduced
to let you counter enemy special attacks
one of their skill upgrades gives you a
dash to close distance between you and
your enemy and this was the main reason
i use them in my playthrough eventually
you can unlock perks which let you
basically makiri counter the special
attacks or just parry them and i ended
up relying on these methods instead of
the feathers
so those are the core gameplay mechanics
there are also health charges in the
form of potions and you can unlock three
different kinds you start with normal
and you can get slow ones which heal
over time or fast ones which heal
instantly and can be used quicker i'm a
fan of the fast ones as they feel like
blood vials and they can help keep up
the pace during fights you can upgrade
these potions with materials from
killing strong enemies and you can use
ingredients to give them special effects
like increased damage or resistance
now you'll understand most of what
happens on the screen this system feels
the most fleshed out of anything in the
game to me it makes sense that the
combat is the central focus and i think
overboarder studio the dev team did a
good job with their own implementation
of this kind of action rpg there can
occasionally be some issues with getting
locked into punished chains from enemies
even if you input correctly on a second
or third hit if you get hit on the first
hit but overall the kit that give the
player is pretty comprehensive and
satisfying to use once you get your
bearings learning enemy movesets and
becoming comfortable enough to dodge
into and parry enemy attacks while
keeping up your own slashes and claws
makes for a satisfying and engaging
combat flow you have to decide your
openings to attack in but parries can
come out blisteringly fast when you're
using your claw claw claw parry claw
becomes your punished dance and it feels
great when you get it working especially
against someone like vark really the
only issue here other than the
aforementioned stickiness of some enemy
punishes is that when you get into the
flow and comfortable with a boss they
often get too easy i think some more
mix-ups or even letting bosses
occasionally parry the player would help
or if bosses had some kind of claw
counter it would help keep things more
engaging and increase the skill ceiling
while there are definitely elements and
enemies in the game that are challenging
when you're learning them the switch
sometimes flips too quickly from
difficult to sailing through the enemy
with ease overall though the combat is
pretty great and it's what kept me
hooked into the game
unfortunately most of the game is not up
to par with this system and this
detracts from the heights that it could
have reached the bosses are generally
not very hard some of them i beat on my
first try and the first boss might be
one of the toughest especially given
that you meet it early on in your
playthrough another boss the tutorial
knight varg who is destined to kill you
at the game's start even if you get the
achievement for taking out his first
health bar shares either some or all of
his kit with another normal enemy the
generic heavy sword knight given that
there are only 7 or 8 bosses in the game
it's disappointing to see asset reuse
here too as i noted before the enemy
design is also overall disappointing the
knights take on different visual effects
in the different levels but these don't
seem to impact gameplay at all they just
give the enemies different death
animations which is cool but i'd rather
have a gameplay change the levels are
demarcated by having some different
enemies in them in that the later levels
introduce enemies like the bow knight or
the twin sword knight but when these are
the same knights just with a new weapon
which is almost always melee it doesn't
feel like much variation this is
especially true because the parry turns
most of the fights into a rhythm game so
giving a basic knight a different attack
rhythm would have been almost
indistinguishable from these new enemies
the few times where an enemy is a
different thing than just a knight like
with the whip enemy or the bloodsword
enemy things do liven up some
projectiles and other mechanics change
up the pace but the game could have used
a lot more of these
i've already discussed the level reuse
to the point that i can't add anything
too meaningful here it just takes away
from the game since it's already so
short plus the environments of the first
two levels are both pretty dark and damp
they do have different architecture
which is good but when you only have
three levels they should each clearly
exemplify different thematic notes for
the player to feel difference in them
the similar dankness between levels 1
and 2 did not really achieve that for me
i will say that i like the lore of the
game it impacts which ending you get and
it is dependent on you completing each
mission and searching out an npc to get
answers it adds to the world building
and reveals a deeper story to most of
the game's major players there are
conspiracies and secret research
projects of injecting pure and vile
blood into soldiers and animals it fits
and adds to the plague elements though
the lack of different enemies to flesh
out the lore hurts for example in the
note to the last level it says that
there are two kinds of knights in the
kingdom's fortress the knights of the
pureblood and the royal guard these two
groups came up as distinct in the lore
and they serve different purposes but
none of the game's basic enemies or
knights bear any distinction so when i
fought through the fortress i never
experienced fighting one group and then
the other there was no difference in the
enemies at least that i could see and
that meant the interesting lore didn't
get to complement the gameplay like it
could have it didn't change the feeling
of killing the third bowman or the 15th
knight with a sword and shield
lastly i want to talk about the final
boss so spoiler warning if you don't
want to spoil yourself then go to this
time in the video
okay so the final boss of the game is a
mimic fight you fight yourself corvus
and he is equipped with a kit that you
have been amassing throughout the game i
don't think the boss's moveset is
actually dependent on what you unlock or
use but chances are you will unlock
almost everything if you play through
all of the game's missions the fight is
interesting because you get to put to
the test everything you've learned both
in offense and defense but it's also
lackluster because we don't get anything
new for the final boss of the game it's
just a rehash of a bunch of moves that
we are already familiar with there are
lots of combat tools to engage with such
as the parry and claw so it makes for a
better one-on-one than say eldon rings
mimic boss fight but it pales in
comparison to something like ishin and
sekiro where we get that kind of duel
between equals but still have a wide
variety of new moves and attacks that
add to the fight's engagement factor and
its spectacle maybe it would have been
better to have corvus be a phase one and
then grow to something more unique in
phase two like turn more crow than human
undergo a dark sinister transformation
that could fit with the corrupting and
empowering blood motifs that are present
in the lore and we do see something
similar to that with one of the earlier
bosses it's just that the game separates
it into two different fights the game
could in general have more amped up
phase 2s for bosses that would help with
the difficulty and this fight especially
could use the buff to make it something
a lot more distinct and memorable it
could even have been a better fight if
boss corvus could use perry so you can't
just spam attack at him during any
opening having a little bit of this
would keep the player a bit more on edge
and it would feel better and more
natural since we have a parry and we're
supposed to be fighting ourself but boss
corvus never parries us
overall thymesia shines during some of
the boss fights but the lack of
development in most other areas
especially enemy variety holds it back i
had fun with the game i enjoyed a bit of
the exploration and the fights but i
didn't get much more of a cohesive
experience other than those few moments
where the dance of combat really clicked
and one final note i forgot to mention
earlier the soundtrack to the game is
fine the main theme is fitting and
grandiose in the right way but most of
the others are somewhat forgettable to
me i will say that the os stage to the
first level did have an adequately fun
yet kind of creepy investigative vibe so
the main theme and level one ost are
solid the rest were so soft and that
concludes most of what i have to say
about thymeja in terms of a critical
review it has its positives but the lack
of development shows in a lot of areas i
may do one or two more videos on the
game such as an endings guide an
explanation or maybe something about the
lore or bosses so if you like this video
wants to see that content or want to see
more of my usual elden ring content feel
free to subscribe to the channel or
become a patron on patreon both really
help the channel out and let me dedicate
more time and effort into making these
videos with that thank you for watching
i hope you enjoyed and i will see you in
the next video peace
[Music]